Let's see if we can
figure out 3 times 60.
Well, there's a couple of
ways you could think about it.
You could literally view
this as 60 three times.
So you could view this
as 60 plus 60 plus 60.
And you might be able to
compute this in your head.
60 plus 60 is 120,
plus another 60 is 180.
And you'd be done.
But another way to think
about this is that 3 times 60
is the same thing as 3
times-- instead of thinking
of it as 60, you could
think of 60 as 6 times 10.
3 times 6 times 10.
Now, when you're multiplying
three numbers like this,
it doesn't matter what
order you multiply them in.
So we could multiply
the 3 times 6 first
and get 18 and then
multiply that times 10.
And 18 times 10 is
just going to be 180.
It's going to be 18
with another zero.
So this is going to be 180.
Now, the more practice you
get here, you'll realize,
hey, I could have just
said 3 times 6 is 18,
but I have to worry about
this 0 right over here.
So I'm going to put one
more zero at the end.
It's going to be 180.
Same answer that we
got right over there.
Let's do another one of these.
So let's say we want
to multiply 50 times 7.
And I encourage you to pause
the video and think about it
yourself, and then unpause
it and see what I do.
So 50, well, there's a couple of
ways you could think about it.
One, you could literally
try to add 50 seven times.
Adding 7 fifty times
would take forever,
but you could literally say 50
plus 50 plus 50 plus 50-- let's
see, that's four--
plus 50 plus 50.
Let's see, that is six.
I'll do one more
right over here.
50 right over here.
So this is 50 seven times.
If you add together 50 plus
50 is 100, 150, 200, 250, 300,
350.
So you could do it that way.
But you could imagine that
there is an easier way to do it.
You just need to
realize that 50 is
the same thing as 10 times 5.
So we could write
this as 10 times 5,
and then we're
multiplying that times 7.
Once again, the order that
we multiply does not matter.
So we can multiply the
5 times the 7 first.
We know that that
is 35, and we're
going to multiply that times 10.
10 times 35, well,
we're just going
to stick a zero at
the end of the 35.
It's going to be equal to 350.
Now I want to do that
zero in that same color.
It's going to be 350.
Now, you might
realize, hey, look,
I could have just looked
at this 5 right over here,
multiplied the 5 times the
7, and have gotten the 35.
And then, not forgetting
that it's actually not a 5,
it's a 50.
So I have to
multiply by 10 again,
or I have to throw
that 0 at the end of it
to get that 0 right over here.
So 50 times 7 is 350.